I was blind before, but now I see.
Docker really does make it easy
to deploy and run our containers.
The logical next step is get Docker on
all of my machines, and I'm good to go.
Kelsey, what is there left for
you to teach me at this point?
>> There you go again, Carter.
This happens every time I tell
someone about containers.
They think that's the end of the story.
To be honest, packaging containers
is like 5% of the problem.
The real issues have to do with
application configuration,
service discovery,
managing updates and monitoring.
While we can build all those
things on top of Docker,
we're better off leveraging a platform
to manage all that complexity for us.
>> This is where Kubernetes comes in.
>> Yep, Kubernetes provides a new set
of abstractions that go well beyond
the bases of container deployments, and
enable you to focus on the big picture.
Previously, our focus has been deploying
applications to individual machines
which locks you into limited workflows.
Kubernetes allows us to abstract
the way in the individual machines and
treat the entire cluster like
a single logical machine.
The application becomes
a first class citizen which
enables us to manage them
using high level abstractions.
In Kubernetes, we can describe
a set of applications and
how they should interact
with each other and
then let Kubernetes figure
out how to make that happen.
>> Okay.
You're right.
Maybe there's still
a lot I've got to learn.
Let's deep dive into Kubernetes.